a mystery solver new hmm
submitted by love from Scotland all
blown netflix documentaries are actually
helping the police solve cold cases how
to make a murder dude that thing got me
so heated after watching I was so upset
I don't even know what has we gonna do
it they'll just like biased oh right
like a lot of it it'll do well so it's
just I don't know I want to I want to
see the cop side now
yeah I heard I mean I heard that he
actually did do the thing from like that
movie but still you fight from because
that's what the documentary wants you to
do how did he felt I really know about
his nephew Brendan Dassey what happened
to him hmm
so he reasons that his conviction
overturned when he got his conviction
overturned last year but then the
prosecutors they wanted to eternal life
returns you want to appeal that because
he stayed in prison this whole time
longest whole appeal thing was happening
but now their appeal got denied and so
within the next 90 days his soon to be
released
oh sure after getting a life sentence
because of the documentary
yeah the documentary helped a lot
because they were petitioning their
petitions for Barack Obama - pardon me -
that yeah guys if I ever get caught
committing any type of crime make a
documentary about me it's going to be
hard to a lot of the plays we have a
year's crazy person so it
oh just like your kind of I printed
abandoned in school what I have to like
the last violent man comedy guides we
have to delete a lot of videos to help
you out thank you party and just the
whole channels inside yeah this man
never act out of impulse or
premeditation
mafia and JK party rages mad dad's for
sure ultimate crime I don't want to but
the law keeps changing so you're going
to accidentally traumatic crime
I mean being you didn't used to be a
crime until a law became a thing I mean
just don't kill people
still generally I don't want to but the
law keeps changing what fits Falacci
McGarrigle of judges I gotta kill
someone else what have you guys heard of
the Netflix documentary series called
the keepers yes by K watt not one single
episode I neither have I but apparently
this series is it's investigating the
unsolved murder of the 1969 murder of
sister Kathy ethnics oh I'm havin it hmm
it's a seven episode series and it
centers a lot about the killing of her
she was 26 year old nun and a
schoolteacher and so um I shouldn't talk
like she sounds like a saint
ha ha ha there's so much like nun porno
and I'm like what like that when you see
nun porno do they also keep the headache
yeah Oh none for no that's baby weird
yeah really weird did you watch the
whole thing I liked the ones who are 3
minutes is like hot stripper things
underneath and you're like I know you've
been naughty this whole time because you
handled it for many many years girl you
dedicated your life to celibacy but you
can't hold back so this is sister Kathy
oh yeah I've seen that all day the cheap
ass so who killed sister Kathy that is
creepy
that's my stuff how do they
smells kinda scary Oh perfect you wanna
hear something really cool I thought it
was kind of funny on really guys I think
so I was driving home last week from JK
news right and then I see this car so
they're waiting to make a left turn so I
could see them they're facing me because
everybody inside that car I'm driving
this way and I don't know why I thought
like ready playing heads-up or something
why is everyone my [ __ ] has something
like a white card on the forehead I'm
like what and I get closer it was a
whole car full of men I'm like on
rolling mm nuns being cars vanilla
choose acknowledge out of it what Oh
idiot about Quakers I had a run-in with
a bunch of nuns to think you [ __ ] about
to go down you talking about right now
are the red dragons in the nun bro
Atlantic Avenue and we had a big Rumble
hello brother port you know believe that
Jesus Christ oh [ __ ] you well I was at
the airport and then I was about to go
in the elevator and then a bunch of nuns
like eight of them came behind me and if
for some reason I was just like man this
elevator is about to smell bad so I held
my breath and I went inside with the
eight nuns why why I just I just see all
that fabric and I'm mighty pops not if I
don't know why you think they do laundry
I don't know just looked musty so I was
like oh my god it is enough you can tell
about my breath I didn't I didn't know
no big bad smell when I see none I think
I think incense
sage and church pews I felt hot I had a
lot of fabric on I blamed the horror
movies because every time I've seen none
these cans and they don't know boosters
Oh pure like you know holy people but I
just get so scared yeah I'm a scary
movie well I'm ignorant you should want
to distract them I did believe in a real
Mensch is an undercover nun
you know what they should do as a nun to
make it a lot better they should just
wear that [ __ ] right and they put a wire
frame over it so the fabrics not
touching them but they can just walk
it look like an angel yeah later on you
know so so nice and free then it'll be
Sun convenient they can't be come from
so just look like walking bells yes well
I wonder how comfortable their thing is
already as is impression and adding more
threw in a whole large IRA upgrade the
you know like fashion changes and trend
change it change so why not like have
them evolve it or just make it out of
like the Under Armour material sounds
like hello like compression on Titan
yeah compression gunsight no probably
argue the whole like well it's not about
what we're wearing it's about the word
about overruns and I just they could oh
they might have restrictions on fabric
oh sorry
oh I thought it was a spider with a
[ __ ] big fly on my [ __ ] hand and
then something happen to the baby but
you want to kill that [ __ ] now
on here and I thought it was a big black
thing or they got spiders oh now you
don't like big black big huh yes anyway
so this article is talking about how
it's really cool since the keepers air
door has been available on Netflix
they've been receiving so many phone
calls and like emails and through social
media like the creators of the show and
the lawyers working and like the
detectives working on this case so
they're saying that there's there have
been so many silent victims that have
come forward since really all so what is
it about I don't even know what it's
about I don't know what to call it for
for yeah so this entire series what
they're suggesting is that her the
sister Kathy's murder was linked or
connected to all these teen girls that
were being abused by priests in that
city what piece of [ __ ] they're also on
they're focusing on these two particular
Reverend and they're saying that there
have been so many victims coming forward
since since this that this happened
telling truth yeah that they thought
they were the only ones so sad so I'm
going to so they watch the Netflix and
then they go oh I know I know sister and
then you they watch it they go oh my god
has been bio-memory
I mean I have to tell the foretop yeah
so before you ask your question I just
want to show you guys is quote from the
lawyer that's representing a lot of the
participants in this entire documentary
he's saying quote many thoughts secretly
that they were the only victims they
thought something was wrong with them
they thought they must have been some
sort of terrible Center to deserve that
kind of punishment and treatment oh my
gosh I'm so sad all those priests still
alive
um I'm not just send them over to me
Thanks so I can dip my hand in honey and
stand and inject them off Oh Jack them
up and stroking them with [ __ ] gravel
and honey hands Wow you've never had so
much fun s before Wow
you get a technique go to the tiller it
is the more scrapes and road rash you're
going to get on the dick you know my
license she's not the only thing because
I smell satisfying that and then you get
out Burnett you shake it up and you put
it in the dick hole and just spray a
little fills up and then just light a
match oh you need your book ha ha ha
would you title your book of torture oh
no fun time goodbye :
thank you guys you know if it's so
prevalent that within the Catholic
Church that there is a lot of this known
sexual misbehavior don't you think it's
about time maybe within the Catholic
Chur state they allow their priests to
have sex that's true there's a
masturbate but they're just in a bottle
and I'm really [ __ ] well that's fine
that you're speaking very scientifically
they are leaking and like oh they're
just um pure the devil influence yeah
but they do adapt a little bit to the
modern times you're in there yeah
because the reason Pope said that dogs
go to heaven now
how can I just get like both [ __ ]
flashlight yeah yeah they should just
get a flashlight bless it with holy
water and then now it's pure holy water
Lou yeah
yeah figured out they're not masturbate
Florrick's is against the will of the
lord but i will rape this little boy
like I don't understand like how that
RORO many [ __ ] years and decades yeah
and now it's not just like this point of
like oh maybe it'd happen to you but
there's so many account accounts of it
now it's just undeniable I think they're
their thing is like well technically I'm
still a virgin if I'm just [ __ ] the
boys áááhole no that's funny explain
these teen girls then they're really
better don't believe that they actually
believe what they're preaching I just
truly believe it they don't care they
can't if they did they wouldn't be do
are these [ __ ] still alive um because
I feel like if they believe in the Bible
so much right they should go by the
punishments that are in the Bible hold
it would you like me to stone to death
I love the tortures in the Bible man
he's adding images listen I think we
could go on welcome to my house office
I'll start brainstorming and I'll draw a
circle tortures in the one line is you
know maybe burning style cut style acid
style or just brainstorm like a
elementary school but not a ttle
character should those actual sides
it's like a cookbook but it's like it's
like four tortures we go we have the
scheming you have to boiling fry grill
go for like torture we have [ __ ]
deep-fried has a name
Rothko to the main father father
Joseph's Maskell he died in 2001 God
surely not alone I'm not sure what the
other one but anyways like these victims
that were coming forward they were
saying that there were only victims from
that father or the two fathers but they
were also victims from police other
priests and even teachers oh we're
[ __ ] up that is - where does this take
place
this is this all happened in Baltimore
Maryland
oh my god it's like in a backyard yeah
yell for pedophile
yeah no news to recently that they have
something like that before coasters or
smite up it's been guys who like take
off the condom without girls knowing
tell seems Dalton yeah all think I did
yell for that will they have like a
forum or something like it's just people
who do like lasting damage to other
human beings this is why I like death as
a punishment it's not fair because they
get to just disappear not suffer the
consequence you gotta have a torture
that's why torture like please yeah why
are we in this [ __ ] liberal as
democratic no [ __ ] punishment
[ __ ] dude how crappy would be for
this kinda like every morning and you
know the sun is shining birds are
chirping in the bar condom is awesome my
name is [ __ ] face his teeth falls out
strategies goes about his day and he
never knows when he's holy crap yeah i'd
be so terrified all my life all your
whole liners we can work whereas boys
yeah i would never be able to sleep
hooked up man using a [ __ ] bar Kicks
down the door he's like punching me in
the face
I know I know productive thing for
pedophiles what they should do is grab
all of them give them all viagra and
then lay them on the golf course and
they could be the tea for the golf ball
16 hole golf course yep 16 pedophiles
everyone is laying there was a dick in
it put the golf ball there and you
barely leave hard are you American face
hard for a long time since I've ever
done he thought that oh my god and if
they're uncircumcised he stretched down
he put the golf ball
he's gonna play hell yeah do it it will
look like Dumbo when he grabbed an apple
or something you know hope you guys
enjoyed that video but if you didn't
guess what you can directly contribute
to the articles that we discussed just
cruise out over to the description box
below click on that link to submit your
article also for the next video click
right up
[Music]